what's going on guys you know the drill
here for brooklyn nine-nine watch logs
at other shows or over at our patreon
page
hit the like button or dislike button
depending on how much you hate our
reaction or like it and uh thanks super
thumb or jaden or whoever else is on the
editing team over there that company
that i forget the name of
awesome
and another round for everyone on me
what's the occasion i just got fired
from the nypd what no
i don't believe it no he's leaving the
show they just kept him on all the
promotional materials
what you're about to see is highly
disturbing but please no comments this
man is in pain so above all else be kind
tisk tisk let's just get it out there
vivian broke up with me last night
i'm sorry chuckle bunny charles wait yes
your food dehydrator
i don't understand did you already have
a matrix get up at home for some reason
i bought this with the money i was going
to spend on our honeymoon to cape
canaveral oh my
i'm settling into the darkness nicely i
definitely get you now
ew
[Laughter]
commissioner podolski it's been a while
maybe because you haven't put any of my
children in handcuffs recently yay
enemies for life
uh yeah i have i think he's laundering
money for drug dealers don't be an idiot
lucas nguyen is a civic leader lonely
island
kiva schaefer directing and he
officially claims you been harassing do
i mean he keeps avoiding me so i
approached him at his weekly basketball
game i told you to back off this is
completely inappropriate no this is me
scoring in your face
kobe oh
do you have any evidence to support your
suspicions there's a lot of chatter
amongst low-level drug dealers chatter
sorry i know i hate that word too tittle
tattle captain i'm telling you this is
reliable tittle tattle
[Laughter]
we have to help charles he's devastated
i hate seeing him like this oh no
i would talk to him but i don't think i
have any advice all my breakups have
been completely mutual
this is the best possible option for
both of us agreed
that was the end of an eight-year
relationship
[Laughter]
he's not even chewing them anymore
oh
yeah
i remember my worst breakup eighth grade
jenny gildenhorn
hey jenny
jake i don't want to go out anymore oh
that's the dress he made her wear
oh that day i truly became a man i
wonder where eddie fung is now 867
clinton street apartment 2a i know
exactly where that bastard is
guilty yesterday i saw him get into a
car with a known drug dealer i didn't
have time to take a picture but today i
came prepared did you tell her what you
saw no i don't trust him on this how can
you not trust holt he's the executor of
my will
hello detective peralta amy tell me
who's there i'm blind
this is unacceptable if you've crossed
the line sir i'm amy santiago and i have
something to say i think you're wrong oh
i'm amy santiago and i'm done talking
good
you're facing a six-month suspension and
you're on administrative leave until the
hearing here's my gun and my badge
you're not suspended yet you're on
administrative leave never let me do
anything cool
good morning captain i got you your
favorite breakfast a plain bagel and a
water you try to soften me up
look my best chance of not getting
suspended is proving that wint is guilty
you continue to work this case against
my direct orders
you astound me thank you sir
every friday i put cash into a duffel
bag and bring it to wind community
center so why should we believe you i
don't care who you believe just know i
hate those dudes now they carved out my
territory so bad i had to quit selling
drugs and i love selling drugs oh i need
you to sign it before i can take it to a
judge fine
all right guys we have peralta's hearing
at four anybody seen boyle present
no
i don't know what else to do i've tried
being supportive i listen to him talk
about vivian's lips for over two
hours yeah rosa
have you ever been dumped in all my
breakups i'm always a dumper i know
you're having a hard time but i think i
can fix this there's this thing that i
do whenever i feel
[Laughter]
this feels right
oh that's so hot what is that it's
coffee
[Laughter]
judge mandel has a reputation for being
strict and proper say something so i can
get the cadence of your voice down i
will not perfect i will not
have a seat detective i will not
i will not
[Laughter]
this is going terribly new plan i'm
going to charm her
you got to do what you got to do captain
raymond holt what's up
what's up
what's up
take a plate and smash it
your turn boy okay fit those feelings
okay here we go they have places where
you can pay to do this
[Music]
we got a warrant but now we need to pray
we can't just go in there in our
uniforms then destroy the evidence
before we even walk through the door
good point captain holt he was only
pretend fired you knew you had such a
game yeah so i found that many women
want what they can't have
i get it ew oh
yeah according to the community center
calendar amateur ballroom dancing
competition i know how we're going to
blend in
oh awesome yeah looking suave
and what pimp suit yeah
jake the overwhelming time pressure yep
[Laughter]
hey
where you going to the dance contest i
am nationally recognized fox trotter
dave blathus and these are my proteges
rhonda shawarma and hank frankel
[Laughter]
i'll sign us up for the contest good
idea oh and amy
your dress makes you look like a mermaid
mermaids are cool peralta needs us to
stall so just keep your answers long boy
are you first i don't know if i'm up for
this i can barely think straight great
use that embrace the void
[Laughter]
were in my car i took vivian on our
first real date in that car
vivian is my fiancee
why never wife
if you could please limit your comments
to the matter at hand i will i just like
the record to reflect that matter at
hand was one of vivian's favorite
expressions
[Laughter]
how did you get so amazing at dancing
jake focus i found a back stairway over
here and spin
as far as i can recall detective pearl
told me that
that
[Music]
he
hey do you want me to actually show you
how to do this so you oh hell yeah
ready
plant those seeds of love
maybe teddy and i should take a class
you
ruined it
maybe
guys we're riding our time what's the
plan
the judges were watching
judges don't care about security
gotcha i can't wait to show this to
podolski yeah i should probably slip
into miley cyrus told you so face real
quick
it's hard to do on the move for all the
weight he was real fired and i need you
to trust me so detective peralta do you
have any evidence you'd like to present
on your behalf
no i have nothing
what happened did holt ask you to get
suspended no he told me to get fired he
said to do it and the next thing i knew
i was just yelling and your mother oh
you're done no i'm not done oh you're
done you can't handle the meat
this is special agent clark with the fbi
we believe that wind has ties to the
ianuchi crime family that's one of the
best crime families
because the ianuchi's have moles inside
the nypd detective we'd like you to go
undercover and help us with the
investigation awesome the answer is yes
the details are my name is duncan buck
detective peralta will be going on an
undercover assignment with the fbi oh my
god my heart just threw up
it will last about six months one gone
boyle
i want you to have my desk i'll sit at
it always
you can have my locker sweet amy you can
have all of my open cases okay that's
enough yeah that doesn't have the
authority to do any of this you all said
it your own
you will be missed
thank you
for trusting me
oh
i'll miss you guys
and your mother
i smell bacon
and guess what i'm going kosher cause
jakey don't dig on swine
to you guys
you'll never beat jake or vivian but at
least you're here
[Music]
hear yours oh i get it that abandoned me
too
oh my god start with this i'm gonna get
some bottles from the ball
make way large man helping his little
friend coming through
the only reason they haven't been
painful is because the guys were all
losers i've never dated anyone good
oh
man
i don't want to be a jerk you're dating
teddy and it's going really well i don't
know what's going to happen on this
assignment and if something bad goes
down i think i'd be pissed at myself if
i didn't say this
teddy's a dick
i kind of wish something
could happen between us
romantic styles not supposed to have any
contacts so i should go
america needs me
bye
what a way to leave here
leo ianucci
[Music]
nice to meet you
dang
let's see it let's see it oh no maybe
less
[Music]
[Applause]
she had a smile on her face
it would be gina
damn
take it away laugh track
okay
take it away skipper
[Music]
i'm playing an improv game what's
calling your nickname oh okay uh yeah no
i mean i i had a blast with this episode
i mean even though you know
every
in a season finale of a sitcom things
they'll get you know like
extraordinarily earth shaking but i like
the stakes that they drew here of like
this actual
little mystery up at the top like i
didn't expect him to be truly cast out
of the nypd for obvious reasons but uh
yeah i like the sort of teas at the top
and then what that did for the working
dynamics between especially peralta and
holt but also with santiago in the mix
too i really like their trio this
episode uh and then yeah just the
overall of him like you know ultimately
being right having that rewarding sort
of vindication
uh because like the way they were
drawing the details of the case i was
like oh man this could go either way
this could be one of those ones where it
looks really incriminating but in fact
it's really an innocent situation but
yeah i thought they they did the details
of the case nicely and then the ultimate
resolution of hope being like look trust
me you gotta get fired and the reveal of
like there's an opportunity for you to
go undercover like yeah this felt like a
nice culmination episode i like that
there were some call backs throughout
this from you know events throughout the
season just like little things that you
could pick up on
and uh yeah i thought this was a really
strong end to a very fun first season
yeah that's true it's all very true all
right time to rank every episode from
season one okay all right definitely i'm
gonna go 19 18
one two
and then uh
four
three
uh i would say that after that it would
be five and six
and then uh somewhere there i was
probably say uh yeah next one definitely
be 11 and 12. now don't flip that 12 and
11
then 9 15
16
uh 22
and uh
in 19 17 and 18. that's how we'll make
it so
yeah you know it's pretty good season
overall um
i told it i said it was fake fire fake
fired
[ __ ] fake fired
fake fired
deja vu i think he's starting to believe
you so
yeah
and then um boyle going through a
breakup
vivian
because she's controlling that's what
i'm gonna say even though she wasn't but
i'm gonna say she's controlling
glad peralta got to tell amy about his
feelings oh man
hate that teddy i can rot in hell yeah
hope he gets murdered at the beginning
of the next season he won't because uh
that they just want to keep fanning the
flame here
but teddy deserves to die a horrible
death and so does the actor the real
life act he's going to throw that out
and
i loved holt here because you got to see
so much of his
unique personality and special skill
sets like his uh ability to use that
sultry gravitas voice of his
to seduce a woman oh you know he can do
it and then he's a great dancer as well
oh such funny stuff
he was such a highlight here the comedy
was on point
and
yeah i'm excited to see how hulk goes
undercover here but gina and
boyle
i don't like it currently
you don't ship them i don't currently
ship i'm not that i don't like him i'm
just i'm not excited about it but
they're intentionally trying to mislead
you here like they have to be going down
this direction of
oh yeah it's going to be rosa and boyle
but it's not rosen boyle they're
intentionally doing that to you even
though there's like little things
planted that it would be gina to be the
one to sleep with him
um but i mean the sex for boyle that's
not something boyle does he's a
relationship guy he's a romantic
it's not good for him you know
it can't be john it's one thing john and
boyle don't have in common
boyle's a romantic one
i have no romance in me at all
it's completely a transactional thing is
that what i was saying
you know what i'm saying john
yeah it's all right that's what john
does he has to hide
hide his uh sexuality at all costs
flaming
homosexuals that's right
that's right don't tell anybody
don't tell anybody about my gay urges
sure bert come in here buddy
i'll feed you guys
uh yeah what else happened in here
hmm
i mean
i think we got the major plot lines
trying to think if we missed anybody we
didn't even get a scully and hitchcock
like they were in the background at one
point they can't be trusted with the
undercover stuff no they who they
probably cannot be trusted with yeah it
could be like heavy spoilers and cosmic
wonder you can't trust them
not as far as you can throw them leaks
left and right
yeah well yeah great season overall
excited for season two season two is
always are fascinating to me because you
could always see like the notes the
writers took from season one and like
what can we improve and how do we up our
camera quality like all those things
that budget
you notice things that shift in season
two
when they want to enhance so season one
being as great as it is i'm curious to
see the opener of season two even more
so
all right guys
thanks for being here benign we'll see
you guys soon
[Music]